C'était très difficile la première fois, le premier mois
c'était difficile parce que j'étais complètement allongé même
ils n'étaient pas autorisés à s'asseoir. Eh bien, les médecins ne savaient pas
endure et non enduré Eh bien, alors déjà
mieux mieux mieux mieux maintenant seulement
il restait à l'os de mourir pour guérir
et supprimez tout de l'appareil
[musique]
le but de la visite était de voir comment allaient les garçons
travaillent
mais comme vous pouvez le voir, il a commencé à s'essayer et si
ça se passe plutôt bien pour moi
nous allons essayer plus fort
attirer les garçons pour le faire
distrait et aide à la rééducation
le sport, le sport c'est la vie
[musique]
maintenant le registre est généralement électronique
pas de vétérans